alright here's a story that I think a
lot of you will find interesting it's
sort of an internal media and punditry
story Dave Rubin was confronted by a
couple of students actually during
recent events one of the events was
sponsored by the right-wing organization
Turning Point USA and a student in this
first video we're gonna look at turn to
Dave Rubin and said among other things
why won't you interview or debate David
Pakman why won't you debate Sam cedar or
Natalie win but eventually it got to why
won't you interview David Pakman and if
you're not familiar with Dave Rubin he's
a cultural critic and internet sensation
who opens the floor to the battle of
ideas by interviewing people mostly
conservative people since he had a
political awakening in which he realized
that he didn't leave the left but the
left had let had left him okay that
that's sort of a summary of one version
of Dave Rubin okay anyway I used to sort
of be friends with Dave Rubin and we
would talk on the phone privately I at
one point had an open invite to do his
show sort of like whenever I'm in Los
Angeles I've tried to take him up on
that last time I was in LA it didn't
work it hasn't happened for a variety of
reasons and Sam cedar from the majority
report has actually been trying to
debate Dave I've been hoping more to
just have a conversation about ideas
that I think are good ones and that I
can defend with facts and he's not done
any of these interviews some say he's
dodging others say he's simply correct
not to interview bad faith actors like
me I guess or Sam cedar I don't know so
a student confronts him at Santa Clara
University a few days ago asks in about
about this let's take a look at how it
went hey Dave so I've been watching your
program since about like early
in college so it's been a while but one
thing that I really liked something that
you talked about here was the difference
between I diversity of thought and
diversity of identity sure now the thing
with a diversity of thaws I feel like
that's a problem you actually perpetuate
on your show because the only time you
really have left we need guests are when
there are members of the intellectual
dark woods just carrots or Weinstein and
they're only there for the bulk of the
time to talk about the regressive left
and so I pretty much wanted to ask you
why won't you have Sam our Sam cedar on
yeah it's recording it okay yeah I think
the guy's just a dishonest player is
just lied about you repeated so would
you be willing to have now that we win
of contre points or david pacman or
Calculon ski all these are progressives
who I'm not even principled I'm not
against having any of them but I'm not
gonna that attack me first I think it's
pretty obvious if you watch what I did
up here but I don't attack people first
and I'm happy to talk about ideas you're
gonna go have to be person if you're
gonna lie about
but it's just not a monthly there's no
winning you know I have a certain set of
rules when it comes to talking to people
and how I sorta behave as a public
person and so we called Sam a dishonest
player he's asked about me and others
and I guess he says in this clip he's
not in principle against it but he's not
going to interview people who attack him
personally or who lie about him or who
slander him and when I saw this I
thought he he can't be saying I'm
attacking him personally right or that
I'm lying about him I mean he he knows
me we used to text each other talked on
the phone he's no longer on the left and
I'm on the left but he knows I'm a good
faith actor right like I don't think
he's including me in that and just a few
days later at the University of Delaware
again he's asked about me and claims Pac
Man has lied about me multiple times
take a listen to this the audio is not
great but you can hear it alright can I
lose less one but I am alright easy
questions is there anyone I know you
want to beat Sam cedar the majority
report is there anyone on the recives
baby Pakman or from counterpoints that
you would be willing to have a
discussion
I know you had him on the show once man
is lied about me many times so that this
is super deceptive in a few ways I mean
first he says oh yeah I did have David
Pakman on he didn't have me on his
current show he had me on when he was
still I think it was on aura TV I had
done a piece critiquing reza aslan and
he had me on to talk about that it
wasn't like his current show since there
has been you know a clamoring for more
left-wing guests but more importantly
tell me the lies I told right if there's
anything I can be fairly criticized
about when it comes to my relationship
with Ruben it's that I've actually been
too nice and I've been too fair to him
in a sense I've been asked to comment
about him and to be interviewed for
multiple articles that I thought might
be hit pieces and I declined just on
that basis I specifically critique Ruben
without attacking him as an individual I
have not
anything that I knew to be false about
Dave Rubin I might have an opinion
that's wrong right
for example I've said I don't get how
someone has a complete political
awakening at nearly 40 years of age
where they go from saying they basically
like everything Bernie Sanders is
offering a few years ago to you know the
the kind of Ben Shapiro etc etc
right-wing I don't know how that's
possible it's not an attack it's my
opinion I'd love to talk to him about it
and he can explain to me how it is that
he had such an awakening he has my
number the first time I supposedly told
a lie about him if David texted me and
said hey Pac Man X was a lie or that
wasn't true or I had misspoken
I would have immediately said I
apologize I don't want to be spreading
false claims about people that are out
there in the world I stand corrected and
I never would have repeated that
so-called lie again it's never happened
and now he says I've loud about lied
about a multiple times and he doesn't
name one I also think by the way that
it's very hypocritical I hope he doesn't
think this is an attack this is just a
critique of what he's saying it's
hypocritical to use this standard of he
won't interview people who make personal
attacks or are bad faith actors because
he does it all the time right I'm not
making a personal attack I'm saying
he makes personal attacks here's an
example of something dave has tweeted
out to a possible guest named Jack Smith
he said hey Jack you're an embarrassment
to journalism and that takes a lot these
days come on my show and I'll show you
what a real liberal is or better yet you
and Jordan Peterson face-to-face I'll
pay for your flight hotel and all the
soy you can drink not exactly the
catalyst to a civil exchange for the
betterment of human understanding right
another example to Sarah Silverman the
comedian who is politically on the Left
she had tweeted something about how
racists rarely think that they are
racist and Rubin responded just like how
entitled progressive celebs think
everyone else is backwards and stupid or
nah meaning she's backwards and stupid
but because she's a leftist she doesn't
even realize that she's backwards and
stupid so for Dave to pretend that he's
an
of civility as a way to decide who gets
on his show as a joke and secondly the
idea that I wouldn't be civil is
ridiculous I've had civil discussions
with white nationalists Richard Spencer
who believes that all Jews like me
should go to another country
I had a civil discussion with Jesse Lee
Peterson who opened the show by saying
that the show started late because he's
black and black people are regularly
late and told me I am a beta male
because I'm a progressive and I still
manage to have a civil conversation with
him so if anyone on the list that was
given during these questions by the
students in the audience could guarantee
a civil discussion I would argue that
it's me maybe Dave's not pleased with
how our interview went the last time
that we did an interview which was years
ago I don't think he would agree to an
interview at this point will be
republishing that to youtube and
facebook at some point soon since Sawada
you didn't see it but this is this I
don't believe that this is honest it's
not a personal attack Dave I'm saying I
don't believe that you're being honest I
want to talk with you about what these
lies are and then we can adjudicate them
let's have the conversation I may
actually be in LA relatively soon and
I'll mention that if I'm going to be and
maybe we can actually sit down and have
this conversation